we're going to return to our top story
now there have been some clashes during
funeral processions in Janine in the
occupied West Bank this is following the
killing of six Palestinians by Israeli
forces of the Janine refugee camp let's
bring in our correspondent to neither
Ibrahim she's live for us engineering
neither what are you hearing and seeing
what we're hearing is that
confrontations are taking place between
the security forces the Palestinian
security forces and the Palestinian
mourners who were laying to rest
is a 48 year old who was killed here in
the Janine refugee camp in an Israeli
race the Israeli Army says they accuse
him of killing two Israelis in a
shooting that took place more than 10
days ago near the village of juwara now
Hamas has hailed him as a hero as one of
its Fighters he was right
during the funeral which has definitely
brought some tension from the side of
the Palestinian Security Forces let's
remember that officially the Palestinian
security forces have The Stance of
non-violent resistance they don't want
arms they don't want Palestinians to
take up weapons and fight the Israeli
occupation but that's the synonym list
here in Janine when where we are there's
a totally different picture where we're
seeing a sense of defiance and of unity
among Palestinians even one of those who
was killed on Tuesday by the Israeli
forces is a member of the Palestinian
Security Forces he was killed by the
Israeli Army here in Janine and we've
been speaking to some of the Armed men
here in the camp they were saying that
while the yard the person who was killed
was a member of the security forces he
wasn't agreeing with the approach of
non-violent resistance he was telling
one of his colleagues a gunman that the
Palestinian security forces are
pressuring him but he wants to take up
arms he wants to fight Israel and he was
killed alongside the five other
Palestinians in a raid engineering
yesterday neither how common or unusual
is it to see Palestinian Security Forces
use tear gas on a Palestinian crowd
thank you
it's been we've been seeing more and
more of that by the Palestinian Security
Forces we've seen uh scenes in the past
few years with after a Palestinian
detainee was killed he was an opponent
to the Palestinian Authority so he died
while he was at the custody of the
Palestinian Security Forces we've seen
massive process take to the streets and
the Security Forces fight against them
let's remember that this comes after a
security Summit that was held in Jordan
under the auspices of the Americans with
the attendance of the Egyptians and the
jordanians to kind of bring more
calmness to the Palestinian Authority
does not want Hamas to be operating here
in the occupied West Bank as we've been
seeing in the past year or so armed men
taking up arms fighting against Israel
but those are mostly
not belonging to factions officially
some of them have affiliations but they
been working together
and now what's what we've been happening
is that with Hamas assuming
responsibility through one of its
fighters of course this situation does
not appeal to the Palestinian Authority
who's trying to show that it has control
on the little lands have control over
and neither we can hear some very loud
noises are those going on behind you and
if so can you tell us what's happening
so this Cemetery where I'm standing
right now was filled with thousands and
thousands of people who came to pay
respect and bury their loved ones here
uh in the junior refugee camp so we're
seeing a lot of armed men who have been
shooting in the air in honor and in
respect of those Palestinians who were
killed so that's why you've been hearing
the noises we've been seeing especially
large amounts of people carrying weapons
it's interesting that we when we come
here back and forth we see Palestinians
who are not even hiding their uh faces
who are not covering their faces so
which means that they're exposed to the
Israeli army they tell us that this is a
sign of defiance they tell us that
Israel kills Palestinians left right and
Center so it doesn't matter if they are
seen they know that Israel
power has the military Advance they have
little access to weapons but they tell
us the other option is to surrender
and they're not gonna do that
neither thank you very much for that
that is neither Ibrahim bringing us the
very latest from Janine thank you